balzers ville bonjour bonjour mme dionne
dont vous êtes en 24e position sur la
liste renaissance l'arrêt modem pour les
européennes du week-end dernier est
également président du modem martinique
une liste qui arrive en tête ici avec
deux points d'avancé seulement sur le
rassemblement national max orville sur
quel aspect des choses devriez vous
mettre l'accent ce matin quelques 48 72
heures après les élections s sur le rôle
de l'europe que pas franchement beaucoup
de martiniquais ont compris sur le voeu
l'abstention ou bien cet extrémisme
galopant chez nous bien monsieur vol de
viol temps permettez-moi d'abord de
revenir sur ce que vous venez de dire
la liste renaissance est arrivé en tête
en martinique avec deux points seulement
dit vous vous connaissez les résultats
l'outre-mer autrement dit la liste
renaissance a fini dans tout l'outre-mer
hormis à la martinique et en dans le
pacifique
conte second en 3e position donc même
deux points seulement c'est beaucoup
c'est à dire effectivement me devons
mettre l'accent
vous l'avez très justement dit sur nous
avons un nouveau regard à adopter
vis-à-vis du rassemblement national qui
s'implantent ça n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
on avait déjà pu voir les prémices lors
de la présidentielle
aujourd'hui ce ce mouvement s'implante
on est obligé de le constater et de voir
quand même une évolution certaine tout
le monde se souvient de descendre 87 ou
la martinique tout entière même si
c'était illégal avait dit non à
l'extrême droite
donc cette évolution montre selon nous
qu'il ya une véritable crise sociale
bien évidemment lié à l'immigration
bien évidemment lié aux difficultés
sociales que la population rencontres et
une certaine défiance vis-à-vis des
politiques
donc c'est donc tout cela qu'il nous
faudra travailler à l'avenir
et enfin pour clore ce propos l'europe
doit être beaucoup plus l'isi
l'europe doit être beaucoup plus
perceptibles par nos compatriotes qui
voit l'europe comme un budget alors que
nous voyons l'europe comme un projet de
vie avec des valeurs c'est pas chose
facile
nous avons contenu cette poussée du
rassemblement national
ici il faut que nous en soyons fiers
mais ce n'est pas une victoire
définitive on vous très personnellement
max orville quel élément de satisfaction
des résultats de ce scrutin sion la joue
perso
vous devriez être député très
prochainement
il ne s'agit pas de savoir si ce serait
plutôt qu'en puisque vous êtes en 24e
position
oui tout à fait c'est à dire le premier
à appeler en cas de défection de
démission de promotion est donc comme
vous le savez de l'histoire c'est un
scrutin de liste lors des élections
européennes bon nombre de députés
martiniquaise pense à catherine néris je
pense à jean crusol je pense à à
d'autres qui se sont arrivés au
parlement suite à des défections et ils
n'étaient pas forcément les premiers
placer cette chance je lai je suis en
contact avec l'équipe des députés élus
j'ai même participé au choix de
commissions à venir la question c'est le
camp le camp on peut se dire que
raisonnablement après le break site
on devrait y voir beaucoup plus clair
alors max orville président du modem
martinique 1 vous avez été souvent
raillés souvent moqué présenté comme
partie très peu mobilisateur dans notre
île une cabine téléphonique
ouais vous teniez vos assemblées
générales dans une cabine téléphonique
tellement vous étiez nombreux ce sont
des railleries est-ce que ce matin vous
siffloter en vous disant c'est la
revanche le max non ça fait partie il
faut savoir rester humble le modem à dix
ans exactement le benêt martinique à 10
ans nous avons une traversée du désert
assez longue qui
maintenant que le nous sommes dans la
majorité présidentielle et que nous
avons fait les scores que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui est bien
effectivement nous rencontrons une
certaine adhésion
alors je veux croire j'ai dû brusquement
plus grand plus beau plus fort et votre
téléphone n'arrête pas de sonner comme
dirait gainsbourg il faut savoir rester
humble face à toutes ces sollicitations
ces nouvelles vertus qui vous sont
prêtés c'est la revanche de max non
c'est la revanche du modem martinique
qui a toujours travaillé et conservé son
cap ses valeurs sans jamais faire de
compromission mais en même temps en
demeurant ouvert comme vous l'avait déjà
dit sur les sur vos antennes le modem
martinique
et cette liste renaissance a bénéficié
de nombreux soutiens or notre espace
politique et médias donc je veux
remercier ici tous ses soutiens tous les
partis qui nous ont apporté leurs
suffrages et qui ont bien compris qu'il
ne fallait absolument pas céder un pouce
au rassemblement national la renaissance
la liste renaissance c'est une coalition
quel est le relationnel avec la
république en marche en martinique on
sait qu' il y à une nouvelle référence
depuis peu didia beaulieu nouvelle en
politique avait participé à la campagne
présidentielle en faveur du manuel
macron en tant que militante de base
vous l'avais déjà rencontré vous avez
parlé avec elle c'est quoi le le rapport
de force entre la république en marché
le modèle en martinique alors nous ne
sommes pas dans un rapport de forces
bien évidemment j'ai rencontré lydia
bien évidemment nous travaillons
ensemble depuis la campagne
des européennes hier encore nous étions
ensemble les les militants modem en
marche
agir radicaux de gauche et autres
personnalités le climat on peut le dire
est désormais apaisé serein et prêt un
travail constructif nous travaillons à
la police
en martinique au sein de vos deux
formations politiques principalement oui
tout à fait parce que ça a été ça a été
effectivement au cpc c'est peu de le
dire
ça a été très compliqué les deux
premières années suite à l'élection du
président de la république nous étions
tous les tous les deux mouvements
membres de la majorité parlementaire
mais nous ne communiquons ne
communiquions paris la faute à quoi
la polémique n'a pas lieu d'être
aujourd'hui nous sommes ensemble savoir
tirer des leçons du passé
mais les leçons du passé ont été tirés
monsieur viol temps puisque je vous dise
mal à dire des ego non il ya vu j'avais
pas de guerre des ego puisque c'est
comme vous le dites
nous étions tous les deux dans une
cabine téléphonique et nous avons décidé
d'agrandir la maison donc désormais avec
les percées maintenant est de toute
façon nous échangeons nous communiquons
en parfaite harmonie
nous avons peut-être des sensibilités
diverses mais nous travaillons
collectivement et nous avons prouvé le
succès de renaissance à la martinique
est liée à cette bonne relation donc
renaissance si je lis à travers les
lignes pourrait être le nom générique de
cette coalition qui s'attaquera aux
prochaines échéances électorales
notamment les municipales on va d'abord
commencer par là oui c'est la prochaine
échéance effectivement les municipales
après les européennes ce sont les
municipales nos groupes respectifs vont
faire le bilan et l'analyse de ce qui
s'est passé vous avez très bien dit la
question sur la question européenne en
tout cas il y a eu des larges
convergences
maintenant nous sommes des formations
politiques il est donc bien évident que
nous allons avoir des candidats dans le
plus grand nombre de communes possibles
vous savez défendre nos couleurs
observer ce qui va se passer tout à
l'heure vous n'avez pas voulu entendre
parler des ego mais ces égouts vont
revenir à l'assaut les militants de la
première heure les militaires de la
seconde heure de la troisième heure ceux
qui espèrent avoir
soutien du ce de ce parti présidentiel
oui il y aura lors des trois il y aura
il y aura vraisemblablement la guerre
des ego mais c'est nous gardons notre
adn et notre colonne vertébrale ce qui a
fait notre succès actuel c'est
effectivement notre volonté de dépasser
ces égos et le travailler tous ensemble
ce que je redoute davantage c'est tout
ce qu'ils vont se découvrir des jeux
vais faire comme vous devenir
brusquement grand bruit fort
oui ça peut arriver mais bon qui laissa
veinage qui fera le tri m'a écouté pour
l'instant les du jeu fait parfaitement
confiance à lydie à beaulieu pour tenir
le mouvement en marche au niveau du
modem nous tous les jours régulièrement
nous travaillons pour nous ouvrir sur
des talents
c'est la mission que m'a confiée
notamment françois bayrou découvrir de
nouveaux talents en politique en
martinique mais en respectant bien
évidemment nos valeurs nos idées et
notre sens de la démocratie que ferez
vous dit si l'installation des nouveaux
députés européens et début juillet elle
va d'abord je vais je reste et je
demeure tout à fait à l écoute
c'est à dire que j'ai encore panique sur
ville non non non non le mérite ou non
je veux dire que vous m'avez de poser la
question comment je me situe là je veux
dire que comme vous l'avez dit la
question n'est pas de savoir si la
question de savoir quand donc il est
question pour moi de me tenir à l'écouté
de tout ce qui se passe à bruxelles de
rester actif de rester réactif aussi
parce que tout peut arriver
extrêmement vite et il faudra donc être
prêt le moment venu pour la question des
municipal nous la préparons sereinement
vous connaissez tous les mécanismes tous
les rouages de l'union européenne bien
évidemment que non ce que vous ferez
comme beaucoup d'autres par exemple qui
qui se disent le temps de connaître de
comprendre de fonctionner de former une
équipe autour de soi sa pointe deux ans
trois auraient pu finalement mais
écoutez la stratégie qui a été adopté
par un renaissance est parfaite c'est à
dire que nous aurons j'arriverai dans un
groupe qui est déjà installée que je
suis comme je voulais dit
les équipes sont prêtes et on essaiera
d'être les plus performantes possibles
dès le début et enfin dernier mot par
pour réagir à l'éditorial de jean marc
partie je crois que si nous arrivons ça
fera quatre ultramarins c'est beaucoup
on ne sera pas singleton
vous aimez beaucoup se brouillent 3 marc
et moi j'aime pas bon papier vous
préférez régions ultrapériphériques
merci max orville merci d'avoir été ce
matin avec ton rappelle que vous étiez
sur la liste renaissance pour les
dernières élections prennent bonne
journée
[Musique]